WELCOME TO THE SHOW,
EVERYBODY.
I AM KEEGAN.
- I AM JORDAN.
- AND THIS IS
KEY & PEELE.
THANK YOU, YES.
THANK YOU.
[cheers and applause]
JORDAN AND I ARE--
WE'RE BIRACIAL.
- YES, HALF BLACK,
HALF WHITE.
- AND BECAUSE OF THAT,
WE FIND OURSELVES
PARTICULARLY ADEPT
AT LYING.
BECAUSE ON A DAILY BASIS WE
HAVE TO ADJUST OUR BLACKNESS.
- YES.
- YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
- OH, NO, THERE'S MANY
REASONS WE DO THAT.
- YEAH.
- I MEAN,
TO TERRIFY WHITE PEOPLE.
- YES, THAT'S ONE
OF THE MAIN REASONS.
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS,
YEAH.
- BECAUSE, I MEAN,
YOU KNOW, WITH THE WAY
THAT WE SOUND, THE WAY
THAT WE ACTUALLY TALK,
WE'RE NOT INTIMIDATING
ANYBODY WITH THE WAY WE SOUND.
- OH, NO, NO, NO.
- WE SOUND VERY WHITE.
- WE SOUND WHITER THAN
THE BLACK DUDE
IN THE COLLEGE
A CAPPELLA GROUP.
- YES, WE SOUND WHITER THAN
MITT ROMNEY IN A SNOWSTORM.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
BUT THAT'S JUST--
THAT'S ONE OF--
THAT'S THE REASON
WHEN WE'RE AROUND
OTHER BROTHERS AND SISTERS,
YOU WILL SEE US--
YOU GOT TO JUST--
- YOU KNOW, YOU GOT TO
DIAL IT UP A LITTLE BIT.
- YOU GOT TO DIAL IT UP.
OH, SEE, YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT, BROTHER.
- OH, YOU KNOW I KNOW WHAT
YOU TALKING ABOUT, RIGHT?
- YOU KNOW I KNOW
YOU KNOW--
- YOU KNOW I KNOW WHAT YOU KNOW
I KNOW WHAT YOU TALKING ABOUT.
NO DOUBT, MAN.
NO DOUBT, NO DOUBT, NO DOUBT
NO DOUBT, NO DOUBT, NO DOUBT,
NO DOUBT, NO DOUBT, NO DOUBT.
- BECAUSE YOU NEVER WANT
TO BE THE WHITEST SOUNDING
BLACK GUY IN A ROOM.
- YOU PUT FIVE WHITE-TALKING
BLACK GUYS IN THE SAME ROOM,
YOU COME BACK IN A HOUR,
IT'S GOING LIKE
LADYSMITH BLACK MAMBAZO
UP IN THERE.
- STRAIGHT UP.
[imitating chanting]